hi i'm trixie mattel musical author of
trixie mattel one stone available on
itunes
and i'm gonna reach into this uh i don't
know so there's mystery but we can also
see through the box so i'm not sure
you know okay we're talking first times
today
first time being recognized out of drag
oh my god this happened to me
it was like three years ago i was at the
hollywood bowl for a screening of the
country bears
and someone came up to me and they were
like are you elmer bud
and i was like yes i am it was so funny
first word that comes to mind when you
hear lip sync for your life i mean to me
it's not a word so much as a physical
reaction
and that is a nosebleed i can feel a
blood trickle here
a blood sugar here just like i can feel
rupaul's
uh bony hand around my throat it's so
fun
first celebrity crush my first celebrity
crush is still ongoing and strong
um paul rudd if you are out there i am
available to you either as a loved
a loved one or hired help honestly at
this point first thing you do when you
wake up
usually what i'll do is roll over from
the pea side of the bed to the dry side
of the bed
so i can catch a few extra z's
moving right along first cd you ever
bought now this is very controversial
my first cd i ever got was smash mouth
plus you may
remember that song walking in the sun in
midwestern rural wisconsin
walking on the sun was something i very
much heard with my heart
first reaction when you walked into
jeffree star's house for the first time
well i said i need to use the bathroom
and he said which one do you want to use
and i said how many do you have and he
said seven and i thought i was tv rich
uh turns out tv rich ain't compared to
youtube rich
i think that jeffrey's six pomeranians
have
more quality of life than me or any of
my family first time performing in drag
every drag queen when they perform a
drag for the first time everybody does
pussycat dolls when i grow up that's
like
the song you wear like a mini skirt with
like a
bathing suit with one like blunt bang
wig
i didn't do that my first lip sync was
on a wednesday at a bar for free
um and it was material girl by madonna
anyway i guess i'm just really unique
at this point drag doesn't impress me
anymore i don't want it like i don't
care how pretty
thin whatever you are i need um i need
something unique happening
show me a house fire you know first pair
of heels i think i had this the same
heels everybody has which is that
that [ __ ] plastic pleaser black
pump pleaser i think everybody that's
like their first shoe is so like
i'm gonna get patent leather fake
plastic
patent leather black pumps i'm gonna be
that you are not that big
you're just a bit first choice for all
stars for winter oh wow well
i know very little about this program i
don't know if it's happening or who was
on it
uh so i would say my first choice i mean
to me my ideal
season has tammy brown as a competitor a
judge
a choreographer she's lip-syncing she's
pulling her own lip like it's just tammy
sammy's drag race and tammy wins first
choice for season 11 contestant for me i
think that you should bring back some
folks who
like tempest du jour or like people who
went home early who didn't get to show
the full spectrum
um you know like uh what's her name
layla mcqueen you know but she has a lot
of time left you know give somebody like
tempest in
somebody who that window is closing you
know mortality first show you ever
binged probably buffy the vampire slayer
i think i started watching that when it
was in season six and i
as a teenager went back and caught up on
all of it it's a great program
very hard if it's time for women first
time bombing on stage
i don't remember the first time bombing
but i can tell you that recently i
bombed
and five minutes into a 55-minute
program
i had to look at the clock and then look
at the audience and go well we're here
for 50 more minutes
it was so bad it was 100 seat cabaret
and they just were not into it and
afterward
i went backstage and i could feel tears
coming so i took my lashes off and then
just sat with no lashes on and dragged
and cried
and then i had to go to meet and greet
and people came to the meet and greet
and i bombed so bad
that someone at the meet and greet
someone's mom said
i liked it like someone's mom i don't
need elaine smith
to like try to make me feel better i
liked it no you did it
first kiss oh my god this is disgusting
i had my first kiss with my first
boyfriend in college
in my dorm room listening to dashboard
confessional
hey you don't pick a music to match the
activity so fiercely
you know what i mean you don't put on
barry white to have sex
you don't put on dashboard professional
first kiss first
cell phone i had the kyocera blade i
don't know what they used to call it a
bar phone i think
where it was just a phone i did not i
don't think i had texting
but i did use it to have phone sex with
old men
first drag show you ever attended i
don't remember but i will tell you this
i remember i was at a pride parade when
i was like 18.
and um this drag queen was in this
like she was in like a convertible car
and then this like um
religious person came up and gave her a
pamphlet and she took it
and she yelled the person like yelled at
him and handed it back to him you know
what else they used to do
they used to come to drag shows with uh
god pamphlets that looked like money on
one side and tipped the drag queens
and then the dragon would be like yes
and flip it over it'd be like have you
heard the word of god
you're in a gay bar how far are you
going for the lord and like how much is
this for you
you're going to the gay bar with fake
money you're more like us than you think
okay first job i was an ice cream scoop
at a place called
lickety-split and the high schoolers
used to come at night and rearrange the
letters on the marquee
and they would arrange it to say lick my
i would have to go into work
and use that stick to change the letters
because i would be like 9 a.m it would
say lick mic
and i was 14 like okay and finally
first time tucking to this day i've
never done this
i'm a recognized championship of winner
of drag and i do not do this
there's not enough money in the world
for me to put tape on the head of my
penis
anyway those are my first times well
that was fun i'm trixie mattel and if
you don't think i'm funny
i'm also a great musician and you can
hear my album one stone available on
itunes bye
did you guys know that um pheromone was
like the most catfished person on my
face
she was a myspace celebrity and she had
the most stolen photos like people
pretending to be her